[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان المسيارتي والصواريخ البالستيه
منتشره في مختلف انحاء العالم وما يحدث
حاليا في اوروبا هو دليل على ذلك لذلك
هنالك طلب عليها ونحن لدينا الحلول اذ
لدينا حلول للدفاعات الصاروخيه والدفاع
وهذا ما نقوم بتسويقه هنا وفي انحاء
العالم واعتقد ان لدينا سمعه طيبه في مجال
الحلول الدفاعيه الجويه والصاروخيه ونحن
نقدم بعضها هنا اليوم
مع دول المنطقه رغم انها ما زالت مفاوضات
مبدايه
[موسيقى]
ان الهجمات السبرانيه لن تنتهي لكن هناك
مواصفات يجب ان نضعها في انظمهنا وفي
سلوكنا نهيك عن انها جزء من معرفتنا فهذه
الهجمات باتت واقعا ولابد من ايجاد اليات
لحمايه انظمه او هذا ما نقوم به اعتقد ان
شركتنا من اهم الشركات التي لديها خبره في
مجال الدفاع السبراني ونحن جزء اساسي من
اي نشاطات في هذه المجاهد
[موسيقى]
ان شركه الصناعات الجويه الفضائيه
الاسرائيليه هي اكبر شركه دفاعيه في
اسرائيل لكننا نقوم ايضا بنشاطات تجاريه
في الشركه تشمل طيران الشحن وتحويل طائرات
الركاب الى طائرات الشحن نحن نركز على
قطاع الدفاع ونشطات لا تشمل الفضاء والجو
والبر والبحر لدينا منتجات في عده مجالات
ولدينا تحويل تام من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من اجل البدء بالتقدير فكل منتج لدينا
حاصل على تصريح من الحكومه
[موسيقى]